wir sind angekommen in der ferienwohnung
in venedig und ihm sagen diese entrust
also ich sage ihnen mal ein bisschen rum
oder venedig
pamela cox
metlife hamburger movement texas zum
besten
wie gestern
lieber herr s
regenfeste der massiv
grande in venedig
sabine peter
egal
mainz
namen wie bei aktien
mai
so leute wetter ist immer noch packe und
wir sind jetzt auf der suche nach
unserer unterkunft unserer ferienwohnung
und es ist aber schon sehr typischen
kleinen sind angekommen in der
ferienwohnung in venedig und ihm sagen
diese ent kraft also ich zeige dir mal
ein bisschen rum das ding also dafür
venedig ist ja nicht alles immer so ein
bisschen älter und runter komme ich
meine ist er als mega schön und so aber
erstmal von draußen ist die mega cool
aber es geht euch das mal ihren ist die
küche also alles super modernen klappen
wir sind also die wird gerade erst
renoviert so die ferienwohnung und das
meer schöner so küche liebe school und
jetzt ein kleiner wohnbereich das hier
ist noch ein bad und hier geht es dabei
raus unseren kleinen terrasse vielleicht
ist weiter noch ein bisschen bild
angeblich habe ich wie schön dass sie
einfach aussieht
ich glaube hier werden einige instagram
fix entstehen aber wir schon mal weiter
hier ist noch ein wie gesagt dass gewalt
weit nach oben treffe
die nummer eins im spiegel zerstört aus
dem wegen kohle whirlpool wannen alles
mögliche versorgung des seite verletzt
ist das schlafzimmer nummer 12 da werde
ich wahrscheinlich penn und fernseher
hier ein weiteres schlafzimmer weiter
nach oben
so geht es nächste schlacht von meiner
kleinen schwester die couch er ist sich
ausklappen und auch noch ein kleiner
fernseher und da kann auch noch ein
kurzer blick rauswerfen weil das ist
voll und typisch das ja alles so modern
und renoviert ist mega cool und dann
schauen wir weiter
endlich mehr aus dem weg hier rum ist
noch zum kleine aussichts kunde und kann
man nicht wirklich auf machen glaube ich
die tür aber es sieht aus wie im winter
draußen das ist echt cool so ja also
leute das ist die wohnung hier
ich glaube wir kommen sich echt gut
gehen lassen die nächsten 5 5 tage sechs
tage sind wir hier und es wird viel
gegessen werden und einfach leben
genießen auf jeden fall echt cool
ja das war es auf jeden fall von einem
turm das wetter ist es wieder schöner
und jetzt geht's erst mal in die kita
wie immer
im nächsten ort
das mal was zum abendessen finden suchen
essen und ticket für morgen kaufen wenn
es zu francesco einem ausgespannt
juli
an
so leute mir aufgegessen und war sehr
lecker fand ich das darf mir durch das
nächtliche venedig hier zurück nach
hause
auf jeden fall schöner erster tag in
venedig wie gesagt morgen geht es dann
nach rees zu francesco und da folgt ja
auch schon riesig darauf
und ja dann ab nach hause